hi I'm Erik Bosse and Avengers in game
took our beloved Tony Stark from us a
man we loved 3,000 before we even knew
that was an extent to which we could
love a fictional character but the
interesting way Tony said goodbye an
endgame and some clues from spider-man
far from home have presented an
intriguing possibility could iron man
comeback in future MCU films no I'm not
talking about resurrection it's not a
pretty picture nor am i implying any
scrolls Spira see I learned my lesson
there it's obviously Nick Fury but
rather could Robert Downey jr. return as
Tony Stark in the form of some
pre-recorded projections or a projected
AI form of himself living on as some
kind of ghost did this mad scientist
have a secret plan for immortality if
ever that weird seemingly impervious
body of his finally stopped tickin I'm
gonna dig into this theory and spoiler
warning again one thing established
about Tony Stark and Avengers in game
was that the guy was pretty obsessed
with his legacy and obsession that
manifested in recording messages of
himself to be shown postmortem to his
loved ones
remember he recorded a goodbye to pepper
when he was stranded on the benitar and
in the closing minutes his family
watched a hollow projection of himself
that beamed out from his Iron Man helmet
and this isn't the first time Stark has
done this kind of thing in Iron Man 3
when pepper thought Tony had died she
found a recording left by him inside his
helmet Tony seems to even enjoy catching
his friends off guard with noncorporeal
incarnations of himself as we saw in
spider-man homecoming when he saved in
scolded Peter Parker with an empty Iron
Man suit a Captain America Civil War
Tony Stark showed off his barf binary
augmented retro framing his imaging
technology in which his deceased father
and mother were projected as Holograms
for him to interact with to use the
memory of his late loved ones to
continue to learn future lessons
and remember Tony's original AI Jarvis
was a digital recreation of the voice
and personality of his stark family
Butler Edwin Jarvis it's a little creepy
when you think about it but it was
probably a source of comfort and
stability for Tony over the years the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is also
established that Hydra figure Arnim Zola
long after his corporeal death lived
as they ghosts in the machine an
algorithm AI hidden in shield servers
his persona in intelligence evolving
over the decades as he manipulated world
politics it's almost like everything in
the MCU the whole time has set up Tony
Stark with the precedent and technology
to live on after his death to continue
helping heckling and even fighting
alongside his fellow Marvel heroes but
what would that look like but before I
continue thank you to sound Corps for
sponsoring this episode
sound Kors liberty neo ultra compact
wireless headphones play incredible
audio they're small and light and they
fit super comfortably they feature the
Grippit technology you'll immediately
forget you're wearing them wait am I
still wear them where is this podcast
just playing inside my head naturally
because that's how cozy these babies are
the graphene enhanced audio has
exceptional clarity with deep resonant
bass and ultra fast pairing with your
device and a super-strong Bluetooth 5
connection and new rock stars viewers
are being offered a special discount
just scroll down to the description hit
the link and find these on Amazon where
you can get them at the lowest price but
just make sure to do this before the
discount expires ok back to how Tony
Stark could return to the MCU in AI
projection form considered broody war
machine fighting a warlord somewhere he
stumbles a bit and then a suit of Iron
Man armor controlled remotely by Tony
Stark's post mortem a eye drops in
carrying a tank boom you're looking for
this or Bruce Banner and Doctor Strange
try to decode some enigmatic cosmic
signal received from distant space they
can't figure it out but then a
projection of AI Tony Stark floats in I
already cracked it boys he's called the
Silver Surfer he's played by Keanu
Reeves boom boom
some have even scrutinized imagery from
spider-man far from home suggesting that
iron man's helmet is visible in the
reflection of Peters glasses the same
glasses remember that Tony Stark wore in
infinity war and an end game and they
contained Starks augmented reality
interface and yes future person watching
or listening to this after far from home
has come out you'll know whether or not
this is legit also whether or not her
planet is still here this whole idea of
a character's consciousness living on in
digital form has come up a
again and many fictional universes like
in Star Wars legends Emperor Palpatine
left behind various recordings of his
Hollow projected self for the Empire to
use to carry out his orders down through
the ranks in the event that he had died
to prevent governor's from breaking
ranks and the empire from collapsing and
in the Superman comics the series his
dead father jor-el lived on as
recordings and Kryptonian crystals in
the fortress of solitude in Tibet II
player 1 the AI of the late James
Halliday lives on as a mentor spirit
guide inside the Oasis there's that
Johnny Depp movie transcendence and
pretty much every episode of black
mirror and fully intending to creepy
adhere this is something we're seeing in
real life two deceased public figures
are being resurrected in virtual forms
dancing at concerts acting in movies and
currently living world leaders being
deep fake to say things that they never
actually said in real life who's
actually believed that Osama bin Laden
pre-recorded a number of video messages
to be released in the event of his death
or incapacitation in order to keep his
message alive so yeah maybe the reason
little Morgan Stark didn't seem that sad
at the end of Avengers in game just
wanted some cheeseburgers is because she
knows Papa Tony could just come back and
recorded cameos similar to Captain
America's cameos in spider-man
homecoming I mean honestly they should
have just told her that her dad was away
on business and then just hit play on
that helmet whenever she got lonely or
sad hey kiddo daddy's here to help you
with your math homework
oh my math knowledge hit a wall a few
years back I don't get this common core
[ __ ] but do you want Tony Stark to
return in this kind of way or should he
be left to rest in peace comment down
below with your thoughts follow me on
instagram and twitter at EA boss and
subscribe to do rock stars for
breakdowns and theories about everything
marvel and in case you were wondering
yes this whole episode was not me it was
an AI projection of me based on past
four Korean phrases I say all the time
spoiler warning again but the whole time
but don't worry I'm not dead oh well who
knows when you're watching this maybe
200 years from now then yeah I am oh boy
I am in an existential crisis now
[Music]